wow what a difference this is without a
radio clock Chris which apparently catch
our breath during the break more content
less breaks people that's what happens
when it's a TV show not a radio show
although I really do miss my radio show
alright are you done
you do a little bit more I just want
make sure you know the playoffs have
been expanded we expected that look it's
baked into the new CBA I mean what was
gonna happen the owners get together and
they vote down his concession they've
gotten from the players to expand the
playoffs hell no they've wanted to do
this for years they realized though five
years ago we can't do it without the
agreement of the Union so let's get the
agreement of the union they got the
agreement of the union so it was
perfectly of course they were going to
expand the playoffs from 12 to 14 and
here's how it's gonna go Chris six games
wildcard weekend to place seven in each
conference three plays six four plays
five and again a total of six games
three will be played on Saturday the
windows will be roughly speaking one
p.m. 4:30 ish p.m. Eastern and eight ish
p.m. Eastern same on Sunday as Saturday
and NBC and CBS get an extra game and we
get the Sunday night game Christopher
and it will be telecast not just on NBC
but also on Telemundo and the new
peacock streaming service that debuts
later this month the answer to the other
various streaming services out there
with a lot of NBC content and that
playoff game that's Sunday night so that
is going to be awesome when it happens
if it happens it is it is awesome I mean
as a viewer it's awesome I think the NFL
is making great strides you know to let
Telemundo Nickelodeon I mean we are
having a little crisis with getting our
youth involved in the NFL to have
Nickelodeon do their own broadcast
that's going to appeal to young kids I
mean that's brilliant
it's kudos to the NFL great job there we
need to involve that generation more
certainly okay yeah the the extra
playoff games are a lot of fun I'm all
for it you know but I also just don't
know if I love it either I'm a little
concerned for the players I am I mean
again you know it's a tough grueling
season as is now it's an extra regular
season great game I mean the Kansas City
Chiefs you know with this current model
that we're gonna go into in the 2020
season the Kansas City Chiefs right they
would apply to extra games this this
year so they would have to pipe no no no
timeout the 17 game season doesn't start
this year 21 21 yeah right all right
right yeah so you're right eventually
the two seed is gonna have to play two
more games than it currently played on
its way to this to the Super Bowl if it
gets to the Super Bowl yeah I mean 21
football games for grown men and the NFL
where we know guys are bigger than
faster than ever that concerns me and
you've heard my concerns too I'm just
worried about it being swayed to the
number one seed that much more I'm
worried about a team like the Kansas
City Chiefs let's just say with Patrick
mahomes and they tie the number one seed
and they're 13 and 3 but they lose some
tiebreaker and now that the to see and
they're playing a home wild card game
and yeah you you you rack up the
percentage chances of a guy like Patrick
mahomes getting a high ankle sprain or
doing something like that and then
therefore favoring the number one seed
even more to get to the Super Bowl
so those are my biggest concerns as a
viewer and as a fan I love it it is
gonna be more football and for the most
part I think that the seven seeds will
be you know worthy football teams every
now and then though Mike I think we're
gonna get a team that's you know eight
and eight then we're gonna look at it
and go damn they have no right to be in
the playoffs but here they are did you
say r.a up I think I said ratch up I
think I did the the NFL sent around some
stats yesterday looking back over the
last 30 years because it was in 1990
when the playoff yeah expanded to 12
teams since then 73 percent plus of the
extra teams that would have been added
to the postseason field if there had
been 14 would have had winning records
25%
would have had eight and eight records
or 500 records cuz I guess well I guess
now there's no way you're gonna have a
500 record unless you're eight and eight
because there's no one who's been seven
and seven and two and then there's only
been one team one team out of what would
have been an extra 60 playoff teams if
there had been 14 since 1990 that would
have had a losing record so I don't
think that's really a concern there have
been plenty of losing teams who win
divisions that's one of the problems
with the current iteration yes you know
I've had seven and nine seven eight and
one that the Seahawks beat the Saints
who were four or five games better ten
years ago in the wild card right because
they got to play the game in a home in
Seattle against that that backdrop of
the noise that that registers on the
Richter scale so that was the beef quit
game right now that was the Beast quake
game where they they actually felt it on
a local Richter scale as an earthquake
when he scored the touchdown that broke
the game open and they had a losing
record so now it's one thing to get that
game at home but you're right you start
getting an eight and eight team on the
road against a two seed how good of a
game is gonna be and and the problem is
and and look there's a balance and we've
talked about this on one hand you're
making it a hell of a lot easier for the
one seed to get to the Super Bowl the
two seeds gonna be more banged up the
two seed plays an extra game the one
seed only has to win two to get there
everybody else has to win three that's
gonna make the playoffs themselves maybe
a little less interesting but it's gonna
make the Super Bowl better we're more
likely to have one seed versus one seed
in the Super Bowl which makes for okay I
keep going back to 1985 oh it was
awesome when the Patriots upset the
Dolphins take that Dan Marino and then
two weeks later it's the Patriots and
the Bears and the Super Bowl instead of
the Dolphins and the Bears which we
should have had in the Superbowl so
we're gonna have more of those best
versus best in the Superbowl well that
doesn't mean crap though I mean who
cares I mean the best versus the best
played this year I would have took
Kansas City to beat the Ragin seed I
know but we saw one of the coolest
endings to a Super Bowl we've ever seen
because you know it added another team
this I mean I understand like I get you
I know what you're saying you're right
more times it it is it's gonna pit best
bus verse best but
best team as in isn't always the one
seat it just it's not to me I understand
their record might be be the best but
that's where I get a little worried like
if two teams or thirteen and three and
then that's that one team that loses the
tiebreaker and becomes the number two
seed and maybe they had a bunch of
players hurt during the year and that's
why they were thirteen and three when
really we look at them and go oh man if
mahomes didn't get hurt in that game
they would have been fifteen and one
this year who knows maybe they could
have got undefeated or whatever it may
be you know but that that's where I just
worry about it too and I think the other
point to Mike is we've seen here in
recent history the teams with the byes
are starting to figure this out which
scares me we're seeing a very swayed to
the 1 & 2 seed getting to the Super Bowl
every year I think teams have figured
out the formula as far as how to stay
fresh how to stay healthy still stay you
know all cylinders go practicing and
doing that and you know that's where I
worry about this too it's just gonna be
too one-sided one seeded favorite I
guess is what I'm worried about one of
the things I'm gonna try to remember to
do later this day go back over the past
I don't know how many years I feel like
doing it and and look at what the Super
Bowl matchup would have been if it was
one seed versus one seed and objectively
does that feel to me like it would have
been a better game you know 2018
Patriots Saints would that have been a
better game yeah Patriots Rams right yes
it would have been no doubt about it I
agree with you there yes you're right I
got it here but that would have been
Kansas City verse New Orleans if you
went one favor one save a year right
Game two it would have been a great game
- I got it right here in front of me
let's go do it let's do it I got new all
right yes in 2017 we had new way to
Adelphia I'm gonna go to the great Super
Bowl we got that right 2017 we were
there to witness that so that was a
great match up and then 2016 we would
have had New England Dallas right that
was the year that Atlanta ended up going
instead of Dallas which would have been
great on viewership - but I know we got
to go to commercials so go ahead yeah
butBut I agree with you you know just
because the team's a 1 seed doesn't mean
it's gonna make for a great Super Bowl
but the reality is we're gonna seem
or one seeds in the Super Bowl and it
could be that five years from now guys
like us will start saying let's just go
ahead and put 16 teams in the playoffs
and force the one seed to play wildcard
weekend and and be done with it because
it's it's not fair
to give the 1 seed to buy and make
everyone else
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports